bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france les origines du
coded la chine qui continue donc
d'indiquer que le virus ne vient pas de
one
quel est l'objectif de cette
communication il y a deux choses il y à
la question de l'origine géographique du
virus
mais entre guillemets l'origine
géographique n'a pas de sens qui a du
sens et de connaître mieux l'origine
entre guillemets du virus en termes de
franchissement des espèces qu'elles ont
été ou qu'elle a été l'espèce
intermédiaire par exemple et est ce que
cela a eu lieu en chine ou à l'étranger
ce qui est sûr aujourd'hui c'est que le
premier foyer épidémique est évidemment
haouran le premier grand foyer
épidémique est à one
mais aujourd'hui il faudrait que les
scientifiques qu'ils soient chinois ou
étrangers puissent se renseigner sur
l'origine encore une fois du virus en
termes de franchissement d'espèces et là
malheureusement la chine ne semble pas
disposé à laisser que ce soit les
enquêteurs internationaux d'une façon à
dépolitiser ou même les scientifiques
chinois pouvoir faire leur travail
alors le gouvernement chinois est ce qu
il a les preuves solides a apporté alors
ce que fait le gouvernement chinois
aujourd'hui c'est de véhiculer certaines
rumeurs comme il l'a fait par exemple
dès le mois de mars en laissant penser
que ce serait les militaires américains
qui auraient apporté le virus en août et
en octobre 2019
lors des jeux militaires awan cela était
évidemment une rumeur complotistes qui a
été reprise par le porte parole des
affaires étrangères chinois depuis il y
a entre guillemets deux arguments le
premier argument est de dire que
peut-être que le premier entre
guillemets gloucester n'était pas
amoureux de ce qui est évidemment une
possibilité
cependant si la chine a été extrêmement
rapide pour mener des recherches sur le
vaccin et c'est une évidemment une
extrêmement bonne chose la chine est
beaucoup moins rapide pour laisser ses
propres scientifiques chercher et
connaître beaucoup mieux l'origine du
virus est encore une fois qu'elle a été
potentiellement l'otan
remédier alors justement pour répondre à
cette question d'où vient ce virus est
ce que la chine pourra apporter une
réponse lors ce qui est sûr c'est que la
chine et dans une excellente position
pour pouvoir théoriquement apporter une
réponse puisque encore une fois les
premiers grande flambée épidémique a eu
lieu à warhol qu'on sait désormais que
dès le mois de novembre et décembre il
avait 2 fait déjà des cas amoral et
qu'il est évidemment extrêmement
possible sur l'emploi scientifique qu'il
ya eu des cas bien avant ce qu'il serait
évidemment positif que les autorités
chinoises puissent fessée les
scientifiques chinois qui sont de grande
qualité faire leur travail et pouvoir
encore une fois identifié le mieux
possible origine du virus
l'objectif il est clair il n'est pas de
faire de la chine le responsable de
cette pandémie
il est d'éviter de prochaines pandémies
de mieux comprendre l'origine de ce
virus pour éviter que d'autres virus à
l'avenir ne puisse avoir les mêmes
conséquences aujourd'hui la pandémie de
la covati sme est ce que du côté de
pékin on se dit finalement qu'il faut
absolument apporter des réponses ne
serait ce qu'au pays qui ont été devrait
me fortement impacté par cette pandémie
est ce que ce sera son bénéfice alors je
pense que ce n'est pas la stratégie de
pékin aujourd'hui la stratégie de paix
car aujourd'hui elle est assez clair
c'est de mettre en avant son propre
modèle qui a été capable de faire face à
la pandémie à partir du mois de février
il faut reconnaître
évidemment que comme d'autres pays la
chine a mieux géré que certains pays
européens et les états unis ou même la
russie il faut le reconnaître
cependant ce que la communauté
internationale attend encore une fois je
sais de mieux comprendre ce virus de
mieux comprendre les mécanismes initiaux
de cette épidémie pour empêcher les
premières les prochaines pardon et
éviter encore une fois que dans les
années à venir une pandémie de ce type
ne se reproduise au sein de la
communauté internationale
mais ce qui est clair c'est que la
priorité des priorités de la chine mais
pas de faire la lumière sur l'origine du
virus
sinon j'imagine que les autorités
sanitaires et scientifiques auraient pu
faire leur travail et aurait pu apporter
des réponses
bien il ya aussi des soupçons qui pèsent
également sur l'influencé de la chine au
sein de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui en tirerait les ficelles de
l'intérieur sont déjà des soupçons qui
venait aussi des des états unis dans
quelle mesure justement cela peut être
une réalité
alors je pense qu'il faut écarter les
arguments qu'ils ont que par exemple
l'organisation mondiale de la santé où
quelques organisations internationales
que ce soit ce réel à 100% contrôlé par
un pays et notamment par lâcher
par contre ce qui est clair c'est que le
fonctionnement des organisations
internationales
aujourd'hui dépend de la bonne volonté
des états et que si un état refuse de
coopérer si inde et a revu de donner
accès à son territoire aux
fonctionnaires de ces organisations
internationales aux scientifiques de ces
organisations internationales alors la
capacité des organisations attendent à
faire leur travail sans voix évidemment
fondamentalement et réduit donc l'om
mais ce n'est pas contrôlée par la chine
mais le fait que la chine puisse par
exemple refuser ou en tout cas de
reporter dans le temps
deux potentiels en quête de l'om est ce
là évidemment ça pose problème ce qui
pose problème c'est la politisation de
fait de ces organisations
internationales que ce soit par la chine
mais aussi potentiellement par d'autres
pays merci beaucoup à vous à antoine
bondage je rappelle que vous êtes chargé
de recherche à la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique
spécialiste de l'asie siens